foreign
[Music]
bikers really nothing
so and I remember driving from Savannah
up to Atlanta calling my buddy
who did ride Harleys up north and saying
hey bro on a Harley is it when you shift
is it one down he was like dude what are
you getting yourself into man and uh so
I get there and there was two informants
and the HF undercover guy and you know
the informants of big biker dudes and
they give me this Chopper right he's a
hardtail raked out uh Chopper and bro I
couldn't have I didn't know anything let
alone how to start this thing
so right off the bat they're like hey
follow us we're going to the clubhouse
this is my first day
so it was uh night time it was kind of
misting it's North Georgia Mountains and
uh they take off and all I'm seeing is
tail lights I'm trying to I'm trying to
keep up and I go into a turn
I dumped the bike I slide about 50 yards
into a ditch and you know I mean I'm all
I'm all you know Road uh
cut up and all that had you have you
ever dropped a bike before no I'd only
ridden a bike for a couple months holy
[__] so
um by the time they figured out I wasn't
behind them and they came back the big
informant who never liked me
um
he looks at me and he looks at the uh
the undercover guy and he says you want
us to take this [__] into the
Outlaws Clubhouse he can't even ride a
[__] motorcycle wow so when I heard
that I was like you know what no I
picked my [__] up and I bent the mirrors
back and you know they helped me get the
bike out of the ditch and I said let's
go you know so at least I won their
respect yeah even all I wanted to do was
go home yeah you know of course of
course so so anyway we get to this
Clubhouse and I don't know if you've
ever been in a one percenter Clubhouse
but they're very intimidating right I
you know I had never seen anything like
it uh and again I knew nothing about it
can you explain why they're intimidating
so you got a bunch of a big scary
looking dudes who are bad guys the place
is dirty it's dark there's there's just
a general feeling of of evil about it
that's how that's how it was for me just
I felt like man bad things have
definitely happened in this place you
know and are probably going to happen
again yeah
um so when we went in there
um you know and I had no coaching or
training or anything I stood there
against the wall okay for about 45
minutes I didn't say a word I just stood
there and I watched these guys and I
watched How They Carried themselves and
how they interacted and I could tell
right away who the president was by the
way they were talking to him you know
and acting with them so after about 45
minutes I walked up to the president and
I introduced myself and I called him sir
I said sir I said
I don't know anything about your culture
and I don't know anything about your
rules and I certainly don't want to
offend you or anyone else I just want to
learn
I want to become one of you someday and
I want you to teach me I want to learn
so I kind of appealed to his ego yeah
you know and he saw he saw this big
gorilla that he could mold yeah and he
loved that and I became his favorite guy
he took me under his wing which made
that informant hate me even more how
about the other agent
or the [__] the guy from the sheriff's
department so he was out okay the other
agent was in and uh and so that that
kind of made everything easier for me in
that case because this guy had taken me
under his wing and now if I had gone in
there and acted like a tough guy right
off the bat they would have sniffed me
out right away yeah yeah you know I
there's no way I was pulling the wool
over their eyes so that and then that
was my first lesson in working
undercover how to carry myself don't go
in there as a tough guy you know don't
go in there pound in your chest yeah
because they're going to sniff you out
or they're going to call you Bluff yeah
you know just talk a little bit about
kind of how you came up and what made
you sort of make the decision in the
first place to law enforcement and and
how the ATF kind of came into your life
yeah I came up totally normal you know
with a good good Italian family
um playing sports and uh you know I went
to college
and I had no direction in my life would
you play football I played football yeah
Lafayette College division one double A
Powerhouse yeah yeah and so when I got
out of college I was useless right I had
a degree in business and economics with
like a 2.1 Cube and and no direction in
my life so I took a job at a bank making
eight dollars an hour in a room with no
windows uh putting computer printouts
into files and I just got a phone call
one day from a guy I played ball with
he was down in the Bronx he said well
you sound miserable he goes come come on
down and visit so I went down there to
visit him and uh I didn't even know he
had a brother
and so we're sitting on the stoop
and
this guy pulls up in a Corvette and he
gets out and he's the coolest looking
[__] I've ever seen in my life
back then remember this is this is Miami
Vice days right he had the kind of fan
back long hair and you know he's wearing
an open shirt and he had a Beretta 92F
stucked in his waistband there and I'm
looking I'm like man this is a cool dude
yeah yeah right and uh he walks in and
it turns out he was a de agent he had
just gotten back from
Peru I believe and he was working some
undercover and we sat down we had a beer
and he talked to me for about 30 minutes
about what he did and it was like the
skies opened up and that's I found my
direction right then I wanted to be an
undercover agent what was it
specifically I mean besides him just
looking like a cool [__] was
there anything that he said was there
anything that made you think [__] I
could do this well so it was it was the
concept it was the concept he talked
about of the game so it's kind of your
skill against their skill right if you
if you're better than them they're going
to prison
right if they're better than you they're
going to sniff you out right things
might end bad for you or you're just
gonna have to walk but it was that
concept of the challenge and of the game
right to see you know who's got better
who's got better skill and in the end if
you win
right you've done something good
right you've taken a violent bad
personal someone who's putting you know
guns out on the street or you know large
quantities of dangerous drugs or
whatever it is so I loved that it was
kind of almost a sport right yes
especially at a time you're working at a
bank and you don't maybe don't have
those stakes and you're just yeah that
[__] you know college football player
everything's kind of on the line living
fully and then you're in this where it's
just kind of getting stale you knew that
wasn't for you dude I mean thinking
about like doing that for the rest of my
life yeah it was miserable yeah so when
I heard about this you know and I could
I could just see it in his eyes when he
was talking to me like the passion
you know and I found that and I said man
this is what I want to do I hadn't I
didn't want to be a uniformed cop I law
enforcement was never even on my radar
but the thought of being an undercover
agent
it just appealed to me and that was it
and as you know you don't just become an
undercover sure pay your dues you know
and from that point by the time I was
able to get hired and worked through it
was probably
eight years before I started actually
working undercover but once I did I that
was it I have a guy who's really really
close to music career undercover guy uh
down in Shreveport Louisiana a guy named
Carl Townley who's just uh we we've
we've gotten enormously close over the
past 12 years and one thing he always
talks about is sort of like this fine
line he always says like look man if I
didn't become a cop I would have been a
criminal he was like and one thing that
he always talks about is that like you
know it's you know one word for it is
maybe empathy one word for it is maybe
respect but that you know you see people
just because they're on the other side
of the field you see people and you you
see the situation that they came up in
and you actually start feeling for them
and you start caring about them and and
and and and I really we'll talk about
that eventually about like sort of
betrayal and what that that that that
feels like for you but why did you why
did you know you'd be good at it you
know I always I always had that hustler
in me you know that hustle
um you know whether it was just trying
to make extra money or whatever it was
you know I was good at it I was good at
talking to people I was good at going
into a bar and this is something I've
always said and it's super corny but it
really is true
if you have game if if you're that guy
who can go into a bar and you're not
like some Brad Pitt looking dude and you
can pull the hottest chick out of that
bar sure you're going to be good at
undercover you have some natural game
yeah I could bring my crew in here of
guys and none of them look like Brad
Pitt I can tell you that yeah and they
would sit here and it would look like
you know prison just got out yeah but
I'll tell you what
all these guys they're phenomenal skills
first thing you'll notice about them is
that wow these are really smart guys
like after you get past what they look
like these guys are really smart and
then you see their game these guys got
game you know and those guys you know in
their younger days were always guys who
could pull the hottest chick out of a
bar even though they weren't the best
looking dude or not sure sure
like what in your words what is game
knowing what to say when to say it no
one what not to say yeah right that's
game it's like selling a car yeah
right that person wants to buy the car
right but they want the best price
there's all these there's all these
factors you got to put in so you have to
know what to say to them when to say it
and how to get that money out of their
pocket how to make a sale sure that's
game man and that's what you're doing
working undercover you're just making a
sale I'm selling you my load of [__]
yeah my hustle I'm selling it to you
yeah yeah so if you can do that you can
be a successful undercover age
foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world something I'm I'm just super proud
of and uh again grateful that you guys
tune in we've decided we want to take
things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become part of this
community look I already board Bam Bam
if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you uh be
good to each other out there rock and
roll